[Musique]
sondage Léger Journal de Montréal ce
matin on regarde ça ensemble la CAQ qui
a remonté un peu par rapport à l'autre
sondage qu'ils avaient fait plus un donc
la baisse
stoppée même une petite remontée mais le
la nouvelle c'est le Parti québécois qui
est bon deuxième à 23% et voyez Québec
solidaire 16 et libéraux 13 et les
conservateurs à neuf mais quand on
regarde chez les francophones puis on le
fait pas pour rien on le fait parce que
beaucoup de circonscriptions c'est le
vote francophone qui est essentiel qui
est la clé regarder
le parti non
il y a une erreur sur le sondage cette
partie libérale qui était à
4%. donc la chute pour le Parti libéral
dans les intentions de vote se maintient
Véronique pour la carque on va écouter
monsieur Legault qui était plutôt
content
habituellement je commence pas les
sondages mais je les regarde
d'abord on a posé des gestes importants
dernièrement pour protéger le français
entre autres pour exiger que les
nouveaux immigrants parlent français ce
que je comprends avec le sondage c'est
qu'on a l'appui d'une bonne partie des
Québécois on reste premier mais faut
rester humble je pense que il y a jamais
rien de gagnant politique faut continuer
de travailler très
fortages
et c'est sûr que c'est très rassurant
pour eux de voir ça parce que dans les
faits
freiner la descente je trouve que c'est
un peu fort là parce que l'aiguille a
pas tellement bougé dans les dernières
semaines dans les derniers mois c'est
sûr que le Parti québécois a fait une
remontée puis ils sont dans le
rétroviseur de la CAQ loin derrière
encore mais ils sont là
la descente se poursuit Québec solidaire
c'est sur place et Parti conservateur
navigue à peu près dans les mêmes zones
c'est la stabilité depuis l'élection ça
pas vraiment beaucoup changé c'est des
marges d'erreur de 3 % dans un sondage
alors quand tu gagnes un point tu perds
un point tu es resté au même point
ce qui moi la chose que je ne comprends
pas c'est alors que de la région de
Québec a toujours été un endroit
difficile pas juste pour le Parti
québécois pour le Bloc québécois à
l'époque du cercle va faire une étude
sur le mystère Québec tout ça et c'est
là que le pécur monte le plus alors
d'une part ça nous
confirme que c'est des militants
pékistes qui sont à la CAPAC qui
reviennent à la maison ok mais en même
temps est-ce que c'est le troisième
l'effet 3e lien ou quoi est-ce que ça va
tenir jusqu'à l'élection dans une région
qui traditionnellement est pas votre pas
pour le Parti québécois
peut-être là-dedans et c'est peut-être
le côté le plus intéressant du sondage à
mon avis pour la CAQ il y a peut-être
là-dedans des électeurs à reprendre pour
la CAQ qui sont qui là sont un peu
fâchés sont au PQ parce que des anciens
pékistes mais qui pourrait retourner à
la maison c'est ça Véronique ouais c'est
très intéressant puis d'ailleurs entre
collègues ici c'est on dit un petit
groupe avec l'autre plusieurs années à
surveiller la politique ici puis on est
originaire au Québec aussi là donc on
connaît la ville puis on connaît la
région mais c'est vrai que même à
l'époque où
Pauline Marois avait appuyé la
construction de l'amphithéâtre c'est
gros quand même là pour le Parti
québécois même à cette époque là le PQ
était aussi fort que ça dans la région
de Québec
les libéraux je sais pas si on a le bon
tableau pour le vote francophone là on
l'a pas mais ils sont croyez-moi sur
parole sont à
4% chez votre francophone là je
comprends qu'il y a une démarche puis on
réfléchit puis c'est très bien mais
est-ce qu'il y a pas
[Musique]
le large puis souper la stratégie
d'attendre avant de choisir le chef
pendant ce temps-là le parti est
neutralisé parce que un parti qui n'a
pas de chef n'est pas une menace pour le
gouvernement François Legault n'a même
pas à s'en occuper puis en ce moment moi
il y a quelque chose que je surveille
joue après jour puis les données sont
pas encore disponibles au Directeur
général des élections mais ça devrait
venir au courant de l'été là la
situation financière du Parti libéral
qui a toujours été considéré comme un
parti riche avec ses immobilisations et
tout ça j'ai hâte de voir si ça a bougé
parce que quand ça bouge autant dans les
sondages c'est sûr qu'au niveau des
contributions il peut y avoir un impact
parce qu'il y a forcément moins de
militants aussi ou les militants sont
moins intéressés à y participer puis
d'ailleurs j'ai une de mes sources
libérales qui m'a envoyé un courriel
aujourd'hui pour me montrer qui
sollicite des dons le comité de relance
part en tournée régional dans les
prochains jours pour aller sonder les
militants de chaque région puis là ils
disent bon on a vraiment besoin de votre
aide si vendredi comme un ultimatum en
même temps si vendredi aidez-nous
donnez-nous 25 dollars alors des
éléments comme ça
généralement c'est pas très bon signe
bon mais ça se bouscule pas non plus
pour le se lever la main dire je veux
être chef ou la chef avoir ok
transfert de Bernado on en a parlé cette
semaine monsieur poirievre qui revient
la charge parce que dit-il le bureau du
ministre me dit chino savait le ministre
dit lui qui savait pas ça donnait lieu à
ceci
il a dit qu'il était choqué d'apprendre
que Paul Bernardo a été
déménagé de d'une prison de sécurité
maximum mais on sait qu'il est que son
bureau a été informé trois mois en avant
donc le parti consommateur
revendique la démission de Marco Mendes
pour avoir menti
c'est une couture dans ce gouvernement
où les ministres ne lisent pas leur
courriel à ne sont pas informés sur des
enjeux vraiment importants et disent que
on n'a pas on n'a pas lu les courriels
où on n'a pas eu l'information ce qui
est maintenant c'est clair c'est c'est
fausse donc il y a un problème de
culture dans ce gourmand libéral et je
veux cibler le Premier ministre et le
goulement libéral
c'est un enjeu qui je sais à heurter
énormément de Canadiens de voir Bernardo
transféré ça a été quelque chose que le
ministre s'est en train de poser des
vraies questions à correction Canada
pour avoir des réponses précises sur
comment ça s'est passé
bon alors est-ce que Michel c'est le
ministre aurait dû être tenu au courant
aurait dû et si oui aurait dit est-ce
qu'il aurait dû intervenir ou pas ça
c'est une autre question le problème
fondamental qu'on a actuellement c'est
la défense j'ai pas eu de mémo ne marche
pas c'est que quand est ministre
disposait une équipe des fonctionnaires
et du personnel politique qui sont
supposés dire monsieur le ministre voici
ce qui arrive et ceci pourrait être
important puis on n'a pas besoin quand
on sait toutes l'émotion que crée la
seule mention du nom de Bernardeau pas
besoin de d'être un génie pour savoir
qu'il faut informer le ministre alors si
quelqu'un dans le bureau du ministre a
pas fait ça
c'est un problème plus large dans le
gouvernement libéral il y a toutes
sortes de choses qui ne se font pas
cette semaine le juge en chef qui dit
écoutez leur manque de juge regardez
tout ce qui s'appelle nomination il y a
pas grand chose qui se fait attendre
alors à un moment donné il y a comme une
espèce de de soit de trop grande
centralisation bureau du premier
ministre qui peut pas tout faire soit de
l'axisme dans le des gens qui sont pas
très compétents qu'on a embauché mais
les ministres ne sont pas informés des
choses qui devrait savoir trop souvent
dans ce gouvernement là les visas
on fait la une ce matin avec des gens
qui attendent des événements
internationaux à Montréal qui sont qui
sont bousculés parce que les gens qui
devaient venir n'ont pas reçu le visa
bon Véronique je reviens Bernado est-ce
que le ministre la même question aurait
dû savoir mais une fois qu'il avait
cette information là doit-il s'en aller
ou pas
ça j'hésite à dire que oui doit s'en
aller parce que peut-être que je suis un
petit peu naïve de le croire là mais il
est censé y avoir une muraille de Chine
entre le judiciaire puis le politique
d'ailleurs il voit vers le disait très
bien dans sa chronique là il y a
quelques jours mais dans ce cas-ci c'est
un dossier qui est particulier qui est
très émotif qui a fait couler tendance
alors peut-être qu'on peut comprendre
pourquoi les services correctionnels
voulaient informer le bureau du ministre
je suis d'accord avec Michel que il y a
une responsabilité ministérielle alors
c'est nécessaire qui sont au courant de
tout ce qui se passe dans son bureau par
contre je vais quand même lui laisser le
bénéfice du doute parce que j'ai déjà vu
dans des cabinets des fonctionnaires des
employés protéger ou en tout cas pensez
qui protège le ministre en ne
l'informant pas de quelque chose mais ça
c'est un couteau à double tranchant
parce qu'après ça quand on s'aperçoit
que le ministre a pas été au courant
mais là on se dit ben qu'est-ce qui se
passe dans son bureau il y a un manque
de communication total mais ça peut être
simple aussi pour le ministre comme
défense de dire je l'ai jamais su alors
c'est un peu de cette façon là qu'ils
espèrent le protéger il y a plus grand
chose on semble
depuis quelques temps mais bon avoir à
suivre Michel Véronique merci beaucoup
bonne soirée au revoir au revoir